the human heart has an annoying tendency
to call fate only that what surrounds
you
wounds from love
unlike wounds from bullets
do not kill anyone
but they also do not heal
never
man is the only creature who refuses to
be what he is
nobody realizes that some people expend
tremendous energy
merely to be normal
the only things that matter
are humanity
and simplicity
anxiety is just a slight disgust for the
future
autumn is the second spring
when every leaf is a flower
real generosity towards the future
lies in giving all to the present
fiction
is the lie through which we tell the
truth
to be happy
we must not be too concerned with others
in order to understand the world
one has to turn away from it on occasion
always go too far
because that's where you'll find the
truth
you will never be happy if you continue
to search for what happiness consists of
you will never live
if you are looking for the meaning of
life
when the soul suffers too much
it develops a taste for misfortune
people hasten to judge
in order not to be judged by themselves
since we're all going to die
it's obvious that when and how don't
matter seeking what is true
is not seeking what is desirable
there is no love of life without despair
about life
one great love
which happened once in a lifetime
justifies all those endless bouts of
despair
to which a person is usually so exposed
what is called a reason for living
is also an excellent reason for dying
life can be magnificent and overwhelming
that is the whole tragedy
without beauty
love
or danger
it would almost be easy to live
i know that a man is capable of great
deeds
but if he isn't capable of great emotion
well
he leaves me cold
the most important thing you do every
day you live
is deciding not to kill yourself
where there is no hope
it is incumbent on us to invent it
you can't create experience
you undergo it
always there comes an hour when one is
weary of one's work
and devotion to duty and all one craves
for is a loved face
the warmth and wonder
of a loving heart
peace is the only battle worth waging
there is no sun without shadow
and it is essential to know the night
i realized then
that a man who had lived only one day
could easily live for a hundred years in
prison
he would have enough memories to keep
him from being bored
reason is powerless
before the cry of the heart
time passes slowly when you follow it
its senses being followed
only those who can afford not to lie
are free
a person is made a person to a greater
extent
by what he is silent about
than what he says
only happy love
can prolong the youth of a mature man
any other
instantly turns him into an old man
a person
is always a little to blame for
something
the only way to buy love for money
is to buy a dog
a poor man's virtue
is spiritual generosity
the goal of the writer is to keep
civilization from self-destruction
more than by love
a person gets excited by money
those who write clearly have readers
those who write vaguely
have commentators
where some saw abstraction
others saw the truth
to persuade a man to cheat
is enough to marry him
genius
is a mind that knows its limits
life does not need to be given meaning
for this will inevitably lead to the
conclusion
that there is no need to live
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe